all right let's now move from the
Sebastian Gorka program to Troth Central
Trump on his social media platform
melting down because Fox News is
spreading Ron DeSantis propaganda now
I'll be honest Fox News is spreading Ron
DeSantis propaganda Trump's not wrong
about that what's funny is he doesn't
seem to get that fox news's priority
here is to maintain access to power
whoever ends up holding the power and so
yes Fox News does seem to have a
preference for DeSantis but they're not
going to abandon Trump if Trump wins the
first couple of primaries Fox News will
be back to Trump and eating out of his
hand that's all Fox cares about uh here
is what Trump posted
to truth social saying quote Fox News is
promoting Ron Des Sanctus so hard and so
much that there's not much time left for
real news there was never real news on
Fox but okay reminds me of 2016 when
they were pushing Jeb the new Fox poll
which have always been purposely
terrible for me has Trump crushing de
sanctimonious but they barely show it
instead they go with losers like Karl
Rove Paul Ryan and now even Jesper who
have been wrong about everything isn't
there a big beautiful capital and
network which wants to do well and make
a fortune besides fake news now as a
reminder here's the promo this is
unabashed Ron DeSantis propaganda here's
a promo for the show Fox did
Fox Nations hit docu series is back who
is Ron DeSantis we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob
he was in the Middle East advising Seal
Team One to advise them you have to be
the best of the best he's a good man
he's a good husband he's a good father
is this Ron desantis's opportunity to
run for higher office I think it is who
is Rhonda Santos streaming now yeah this
is the epitome of uh of news attainment
right I mean this is this is not meant
to be informative this is supposed to be
entertaining to the Fox News audience
and it is over propaganda so Trump isn't
wrong to be posting about that lastly
Trump then posting uh about polls uh
Trump crushes DeSantis in Fox News poll
and again it is not untrue when you look
at the polling data right now when you
have multi-way polls meaning Trump
DeSantis Haley Tim Scott Mike Pence Mike
Pompeo and whoever else Trump does quite
well when it is Trump versus DeSantis
head on it is much less good for Donald
Trump and so Trump is not wrong about
that we are going to continue following
the polling but most importantly we are
going to continue following the growing
Civil War within the Republican Party
related to this CPAC starts tonight
the conservative political action
conference it's going to be a pretty low
end CPAC because cpac's organizer Matt
schlapp has been accused of groping a
male staffer uh despite being anti-gay
personally
um and this seems to have led to a lot
of no's for people who have been invited
to CPAC we are going to start our live
coverage of CPAC Tonight on YouTube
twitch and Facebook so I hope you will
tune into that in my curiosity about
this year's CPAC this year's first CPAC
they seem to do it five times a year now
is going to be do they take any kind of
overt position on the 2024 Republican
primary does CPAC remain overtly
pro-trump does CPAC become agnostic do
they pretend there is no primary going
on is it just up to whoever speaks one
of the opponents of trump Vivek
ramaswamy whose campaign is not exactly
launched with much fanfare he is
actually going to be a speaker at CPAC
so it's going to be a very interesting
thing to see it will be live starting
tonight on YouTube twitch and Facebook I
hope you will join me and remember you
can get it all truly get it all on the
main YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show if you are not yet
subscribed Please Subscribe folks this
is my Jeb Bush please clap moment please
subscribe
one of our sponsors is private internet
access most apps and websites send tons
of your personal information to tech
companies and data Brokers based on your
IP address they have a disturbingly
accurate understanding of who you are
and what you do online even when you're
using incognito mode but you can put an
end to it by using a VPN the only one I
use is private internet access because
it's the only VPN that has proven in
court multiple times they are not
logging your activity they're no log
practices are even independently audited
by Deloitte private internet access also
hides your activity from your internet
service provider who is also usually
logging everything you do Online private
internet access is also lightning fast
for downloads and streaming content
normally only available in other
countries private internet access
couldn't be more simple take a second to
download it turn it on that's it you
don't need to know anything about
computers go go to Pia vpn.com Pacman to
get 83 off that's only 203 a month and
you'll get four months free the link is
down below